thanks for joining us this morning
my name is Steve Calendar I'm the
Herbert Hoover professor of public and
private management at Stanford's
Graduate School of Business here at
Stanford my research is focused on
political economy which means the
intersection of politics and economics
or to put it another way the
intersection of business and government
I have a particular interest in these
issues in highly innovative industries
where there's a lot changing and a lot
happening this makes for an interesting
problem for new startups new innovators
that are trying to enter a regulated
market as well as for the incumbents who
are trying to protect their turf it also
presents an interesting problem for the
regulators in how to regulate a rapidly
changing innovative industry my other
specialty in research and teaching here
at Stanford is crisis management and I'm
going to talk about that a little bit
more in a few minutes so I'm Ken shots
I'm the David and Dan Barlow professor
of political economy and like Steve I'm
kind of half a political scientist in
half an economist much of my research
over the course of my career has focused
on the relationships between citizens
and governments focusing on topics of
electoral accountability in different
forces that come into play including
political pandering more recently I've
been focusing on the process of policy
development entrepreneurship and
creation as well as some topics that are
very tightly related to business
government relations one of those topics
is political risk which is obviously a
huge issue in many countries around the
world and another topic that I've been
working on a little bit along with Steve
and our colleague Donna Fatih is the
structure of industry level self
regulation when firms or an industry try
to hold themselves to a higher standard
than what is actually required by the
law I'm going to start off by giving a
quick overview of what we're going to be
doing in this webinar so obviously there
is a lot of government induced
turbulence in the business world today
and a lot of that time that turbulence
feels incredibly unpredictable hard to
handle hard to assess and hard to manage
and our perspective here at the Graduate
School of Business is that some of those
factors are hard to understand hard to
predict and hard to manage however some
of them are actually reasonably
predictable and combined it can can be
analyzed by trying to understand the
logic of how governmental incentives in
institutions function now understanding
these things you know you might think
this is just something that needs to be
done by government relations and public
relations professionals in those
functions within companies but it turns
out that this is stuff that is crucial
for all senior level executives whether
we're talking about folks in the c-suite
whether we're talking about folks who
are country managers or people who are
rapidly rising up into those positions
that's why a couple decades ago actually
we at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business innovated by establishing the
first MBA course in business and society
or business and government relations
well we sometimes call non-market
strategy more recently we've extended
that into this executive education
program that Steve and I lead we'll say
a little bit more about that stuff later
but you know you signed up for a webinar
to hear about turbulent time so let's
talk about some examples so for a first
example Steve will talk about some stuff
that's been going on all right thanks
again much appreciate it all right so to
give you a taste of what we do here at
Stanford and what we do in our executive
education program we thought we'd give
you an example of a current crisis
that's unfolding to give you a sense of
how hugely complex crises are how they
seem to come out of nowhere and a
notoriously hard to predict but yet they
have a consistent structure we by
understanding that structure we can
begin to predict how the crisis will
unfold we can even begin to predict
where these crises may come from and
with that understanding we can capture
some of the value that's at stake crises
are notoriously hard to predict but what
we can predict is that a crisis will
happen and there's enough value at stake
in a crisis that being able to predict
even noisily how that crisis will unfold
will allow you to add a lot of value to
organization so the example I wanted to
talk about today involves a very
sophisticated very professional very
successful organization some of their
successes in handling their crisis but
also some of their failures and it goes
to show how difficult crisis is a crisis
is to manage even for sophisticated
professional organizations these are not
easy but we can do better so the example
I wanted to talk about is been occurring
here in the United States and it
involves the NFL the National Football
League
right so those in the US I'm sure you
have seen this but I believe around the
world this has been an issue some of the
players have taken the opportunity
during or before the game begins to
engage in a peaceful symbolic protest
during the playing of the anthem so
several of the players a minority of the
players but a non-trivial numbers of the
players have been protesting by taking a
seat or taking a knee more popularly
during the playing of the anthem this
has led to a firestorm of attention here
in the United States all right but the
first question we can ask is what are
they protesting and why are they doing
it in this way well it turns out that
protests during the nap playing of the
national anthem has a long history in
this country for over a hundred years
minorities and particularly
african-american minorities have been
protesting during the national anthem in
to promote their and raise awareness
around the issue of injustice in the
community perhaps the most famous
instance of a protest during the anthem
came during the 1968 Olympics during the
medal ceremony for the 200 meters when
the first place getter and the third
place there were gold medalist in the
bronze medallist bowed their heads and
raised their fists in protest during the
playing of the anthem and said this
tactic has a long history the players in
the NFL engaged it in the traditional
way it was peaceful it was
non-disruptive it didn't interfere with
anyone elses enjoyment or appreciation
of the anthem but nevertheless it was a
very prominent display of protest the
players were protesting the mistreatment
or their perceived mistreatment
of african-americans and minorities in
this country in the last few years has
been a raise or increasing awareness
again around this issue and the rise of
what's become known as the black lives
matter movement so this is having a
moment as having a grabbing attention in
the country and has become an issue in
to everyone here and so the several
prominent NFL players use this
opportunity use their platform in the
NFL to protest this situation during the
anthem all right said this was the
situation that was happening what
happened when the players did protest
well they were wise widely praised by
some for using their platform and taking
a position on a social issue athletes
are often criticized for not caring
about anything beyond the lines of their
field these athletes were taking
position they were thinking about the
issue and taking an action that what
they knew would upset some all right so
this was widely praised by some but it
was broadly criticized by others many
fans of the NFL were not supportive of
the movement and in particular we're not
supportive of the protest itself all
right so this is a problem that arose
for the NFL and it really put the NFL in
a tight spot it's essentially left the
NFL in a crisis they had two big groups
of stakeholders well firstly of multiple
groups their players a core group of
their players who were protest using the
NFL games as a protest but then amongst
the broader audience the audience become
polarized some in strong support some in
strong opposition against this protest
and this is a never never a situation an
organization wants to be in and it led
to the NFL being in a crisis alright so
what should the league do about the
crisis just like a company having a
floor in their product or something else
going wrong this was bringing a whole
lot of wanted attention and a whole lot
of unwanted emotion towards the NFL so
let the figure out what to do with it
the first choice they faced was well
what are the protests mean are these
expressions of free speech should we be
proud of the athletes for expressing to
you
using this freedom and disk in the
United States to express their opinion
and express their political preferences
or was the protest during the anthem
itself an insult to the fans was it a
distraction from what people came to see
which was a football game was it
inappropriate that they were using a
football game to protest a political
issue and in particular what was
particularly sensitive in this country
the opponents of the protest said that
they were protesting not just against
the fans but they were protesting
against the military that the flag
represented the military our armed
forces are over out out of the country
defending the country lose get risking
their lives and the NFL players were
protesting in front of that flag and so
it was an insult to the military and so
both sides are very passionate and both
sides had very strong foundations for
their opinion and that's why it was such
a tough spot for the NFL both sides
incidentally called for a boycott of the
NFL unless they either endorsed and
promoted the protest or they banned the
protests and said it was really a tough
spot for the NFL you got two sides are
asking for them to do something that are
mutually exclusive they can't ban the
protest and support them at the same
time all right so what can the NFL do
this is the kind of crisis that strikes
not just the NFL but companies and
organizations all across the world these
crises are seeming come seemingly out of
nowhere they're sudden they're important
and often they have no clear solution
and the clock is ticking on making a
decision the more time that goes on the
more time you take to make a decision
the worse your situation is becoming it
said this is how we're going to think
about a crisis this is how we want to
understand these crises this phenomenon
that happens again and again and again
to all sorts of organizations in the
program in our strategy beyond market
executive education program and in our
teaching here at Stanford we analyze
crises systematically we start to build
up tools and frameworks to understand
where they come from how they evolve and
how you as a manager within an
organization can pursue strategies and
tactics to optimally handle the
the crisis we also develop the skills on
how to handle the crisis under the heat
of the spotlight we engage in crisis
simulations to try to prepare you for
exactly these sorts of situations we
don't have time to do all that this
morning but what I wanted to do to give
you an idea of how we can think
systematically about these crises is I
want to focus on three aspects of the
crisis and the strategic problem the NFL
and the other players involved faced to
give you an idea about how thinking
systematically about these crises can
put us in a better position to develop a
strategic response all right the first
thing I want to talk about is the
protest themselves and just how much
attention these protests gathered all
right so the fact that a protest is
going on is not news protests go on
every day in all walks of life so the
fact that this generated media coverage
was not a surprise because this wasn't a
run-of-the-mill protest this involved
very a very sensitive issue that
resonated with all members of the public
it was also involving celebrities or
football players all right so the fact
that this particular protest generated
attention was not news however that's
not the end in how we try to analyze
crisis what we want to think about is
sure this is going to generate news
coverage but what's going to happen next
well what happened next was it turned
into a firestorm of attention right in
large part that was caused by the
turbulent political times in King in
chief Donald Trump the President of the
United States who used this crisis as an
opportunity to further his own ends
I said Donald Trump began to tweet out
how the NFL was weak and that they
should ban these protests they should in
fact kick the players out of the league
and as is he style of going overboard
even questioned whether the players
should be allowed to stay in the country
so that was a huge shock and that really
took this brewing crisis that was
constrained to the league and made it a
huge political issue and made it the
political issue in this country for a
number of weeks last year all right what
I want to emphasize is that this
shouldn't be a
surprise it shouldn't be a surprise that
a protest or any incident that can
generate some attention has the
potential to explode into a bigger issue
all too often managers and organizations
when I talk to her in a crisis or throw
up their hands and say well you can't
blame me how could have I predicted that
what I think is entirely predictable is
that this course type of escalation
would happen on this issue and so let's
begin by thinking about Trump and and
why he got involved for all the things
Donald Trump is he when it comes to the
media he's not random he's not acting
recklessly alright he is for all these
other you know positives and negatives
he's very talented exploiter of public
opinion and public attention and so for
him this was an entire very attractive
episode for incident for him to get
involved in alright to understand this I
want to emphasize two things the first
one is is that attention the crisis
itself is valuable precisely because
this was generating media attention
itself is important for the league but
the fact that it is generating attention
is important for what else that
attention will cause attention is
difficult to get it's expensive
companies around the world are
advertising spending huge dollars to try
to bring attention to them that's what
we do when we advertise we're trying to
grab people's attention and make them
look at us in a crisis and in this case
the NFL they have more attention than
they know what to do with so what
happens when you get all of this
attention well the other people out
there who want to tension instead of
trying to generate it themselves they
come into your crisis your crisis
becomes a strategic opportunity for them
to exploit for their own ends and that's
what exactly what happened with the NFL
and Donald Trump's involvement here
Donald Trump was looking for a cause
where he could fire up his base this is
basically to the extent he has won a
political strategy that he is employed
since he joined the campaign trail
several years ago right and so from the
NSF Fell's perspective what they've got
to realize or what they should have
they had the attention and so that
attention is going to attract other
people who want attention so that's why
issues that generate some attention
we need to worry not just about the
coverage and the media attention that
first date but how that in turn is going
to lead to a snowball effect and by
understanding theory of the media and
understanding the incentives of other
actors we start to understand and and be
able to predict this escalation in
crisis and that's going to inform at our
strategies one final note on Donald
Trump and his involvement in this issue
many thought or many were surprised when
he got involved and attacked the NFL
that he thought he would be an ally with
the NFL they have overlapping audience
the NFL's audience skews towards Donald
Trump's base and they both benefit from
emphasizing patriotism and that's why
the NFL is having these the playing of
the national anthem in the first place
one thing we want to remember in a
crisis is that interests Trump all I'm
sorry for that sorry for the pun but
interests the interest of each actor of
each stakeholder is what matters that to
them the most and so even though Donald
Trump in the NFL may have been natural
allies this crisis for the NFL offered
an opportunity to Donald Trump that he
just couldn't turn down the second thing
I want to emphasize is the objective of
the organization the objective of the
NFL in this situation what I what is the
NFL trying to achieve do they want to
resolve the disagreement between the
players and the fans all right one way
to think about this crisis is that
there's a disagreement between employees
and customers you've got the workers who
were protesting the custer's segment of
the customers are unhappy it's natural
in business to try to figure out what is
the core of that problem and to resolve
it maybe we need to get rid of the
players maybe we need to abandon those
customers or maybe we need to figure out
some common ground in normal business
times resolving their difference between
those two groups is how we think about
how we think about a business problem
and how we go about solving it but
crises are different crises are
different because the issue itself all
right what we need to do is not focus on
the issue itself but try
to focus on how we can solve this crisis
situation alright when we think about
this difference between the players and
the segments of the fans we realize it's
an unresolvable problem at the NFL isn't
going to be able to solve the social
ills of this country that have been
brewing for hundreds of years alright so
a solution in this case is all but
impossible but it does point to a
strategy the NFL should pursue what it
points to is that the NFL can't solve
the problem and what it needs to do
basically is to make people stop caring
about the problem or to make people
forget that the NFL is involved here
what the NFL needs to remember is that
this problem exists beyond them
and due to the actions of themselves and
some others they've been brought into
the center of this political fight and
so what we start to understand when we
think about crisis and we focus on what
the actual goal of the organization is
we realize that they don't want to solve
the problem like you would a normal
business problem what they want to do is
move away or defuse the problem and so
that starts to suggest as tactics and
the strategy the NFL can pursue one
solution which they pursued last summer
was to just let it play out
and so the idea was just let the players
protest don't take a strong position for
or against them and hope that this
political issue this social issue sort
of moves on from them and they stopped
being the focus of attention and so
often in a crisis letting it play out
can be the best strategy all right but
there's one caveat or one question you
want to ask before choosing that
strategy and that is if you let it play
out
what will happen to the issue will it
get bigger and bigger and bigger or it
all will it fizzle out and in this case
I think there's a good argument that the
NFL played it right - just let it let it
play out all right why is that
well the protests are on the field so
it's limited to the NFL players these
protests can't grow and grow and grow at
least in the context of the NFL if they
go outside the stadium another situation
that's fine for the NFL and the other
thing that the NFL should keep in mind
is that there's nothing that is being
asked of them there's nothing they can
do and so there's no pressure building
upon them
solve this problem and so by just
letting it play out they can hope that
attention moves on all right so the NFL
played this crisis well in last summer
and last year by understanding that
their objective or their ability didn't
involve solving the problem and so they
had to position themselves to get out of
the middle of that problem but not every
organization has a foolproof has these
crises completely solved and that's what
made the NFL's recent action last month
particularly surprising at their owners
meeting they came out and announced that
they had a new policy that the policy
was that either the pros the players if
they were gonna protest the only
allowable protest would be to stay in
the locker room and that if they came
onto the field they had to stand for the
national anthem and if they kneeled not
the player but the team would be would
be fined all right so what this tell you
what I think that indicates to me is the
NFL has made a mistake with that policy
because what's going to happen this
created a whole lot of attention about
well what's going to happen next year
will the pro clothes protest will they
stay in the locker room and of course
Donald Trump loving the attention that
this crisis is giving reinserted himself
into the issue so for an issue a crisis
that was starting to fade away and we're
starting to move on from the NFL by
announcing this policy which I think
made some of the owners happy it allowed
them to take a stand and and express
their opinion but by doing so they made
the issue about them again and this is
going to cause them a lot of problems I
bet you when the season starts later
this year that all of the attention in
week one will be again around the NFL in
these anthem protests the third and
final thing I want to emphasize about
this crisis is crisis planning itself
what is really interesting about this
episode or is one an interesting element
about it is that the fact that the
players are required or expected to
stand for the anthem was in fact an NFL
idea until relatively recently the
players stayed in the locker room during
the anthem but the NFL saw an
opportunity to exploit the positive
imagery the positive marketing around
the national anthem and began demanding
that the teams come on to the field and
the players stand for the anthem
their idea was they were gonna have
their superstar players on the field in
this imagery of the anthem very
patriotic and good for the league and
from their perspective I think they
probably would have thought this is an
easy win patriotism everybody's for that
how could this go wrong
I'd like to bed that when they change
this policy a decade or so ago that no
one in the NFL headquarters what's
through the implications of what it
meant to have the players on the field
for the anthem now remember these
protests were not created in this
situation these protests during the
anthem particularly by the
african-american community has been
going on for a hundred years all right
so that's a good example of the ability
or the power of crisis planning and
preparation what we want to be thinking
about is thinking through the game tree
to understand if we do this how will
this play out will it generate a crisis
and good crisis preparation is thinking
about thinking through that game tree
and coming back up to the decision know
today and forming policies and
strategies then to avoid that from
happening all right so this crisis was
the doing at the NFL and it exploded in
a very predictable way all right
unfortunately for the NFL they didn't
seem to anticipate it they started the
hit they handled it well when it was its
most intense but their most recent
actions indicate that even they a very
rich very successful organization is
struggling with how to handle the crisis
we're never going to be able to predict
crisis perfectly all right but there is
so much value at stake by thinking
through these basic systemic factors
we're going to be in a better position
to capture more value and that's what we
try to get out of strategic crisis
management like the handed back to my
colleague Ken who's going to talk a
little bit more about some other issues
of the day thanks Steve so I'm gonna
talk about some other recent examples
I'm not going to go into them and quite
as much depth as Steve did on this NFL
example but you know if you read the
news and watch the news you hear a ton
about political turbulence all sorts of
major dramatic governmental decisions
that have substantial effects and
implications for companies you move this
ranges from brexit to you know the
change of path
policy in the United States 2d
monetization and Modi's India I'm going
to talk briefly about four examples and
I'm going to give a couple of
observations about each of these
examples so the first example has to do
with privacy and the use of Internet
data especially for targeted advertising
so those of you who are in the United
States know that this has become quite a
big issue especially for facebook after
the 2016 presidential election but for a
long time questions of privacy and use
of data have been an even bigger issue
in the European Union in part this is
for cultural reasons but it's also
because of the regulatory structure for
the European Union as an institution and
this regulatory structure both it has
existed in the past and as it continues
to develop in the future has really big
implications in shaping the strategy
options for companies like Google
Facebook and many other recom urse
companies so the interesting thing that
this example raises is that some of the
time turbulence is not just due to the
government actually a lot of the
turbulence in this example is induced by
technological change so we have a change
in technology the greatly enhances the
prospect or ability of companies to do
things that might be good for current
profits but can infringe on people's
deeply held sense of their individual
right to privacy and another sort of
related point not directly on this
example but I think it's worth
mentioning is that turbulence sometimes
is due to company's own strategies
sometimes the companies themselves are
the ones causing the turbulence in fact
around Silicon Valley we have a term for
companies that cause turbulence we call
them disruptive innovators you know
everyone in Silicon Valley loves
disruptive innovators disruptive
innovation this disruptive innovation
that it's all fantastic and wonderful
and it's created a whole bunch of value
for companies a whole bunch of benefits
for society and it also is in the
perspect
of those who are being disrupted a big
problem because not everyone loves
disruptive innovation those who are
being disrupted are not always so keen
on it so who is disrupted by disruptive
innovators well in some sense it can be
consumers who are disrupted you know in
terms of the practices and expectations
that they have or maybe it's social
norms that are disrupted so that's what
we see in this you know all these
examples of the use of targeted
advertising personal information and
stuff like that with Internet companies
so some of the time that's who's
disrupted but other times it's actually
competitors who are disrupted by one
company's disruptive innovation so one
of the things that we examine in the
program and that actually Steve has
taken the lead and thinking about very
systematically is how companies will
respond to disruptions of their existing
practices that come along when other
companies are engaging in disruptive
innovation the second example that I
want to talk about is expropriation
there's a very different sort of topic
so the point of expropriation is
sometimes the turbulence comes from
companies but sometimes it really comes
from the politicians that's what
expropriation is sort of about so I
think a good example or in a good
extreme example of expropriation there's
all sorts of expropriation there's
creeping expropriation there's currency
controls and then there's government's
just coming in instead of taking over
companies so I'll talk a little bit
about one such example which is when the
Argentine government a few years ago
reen Ashin alized YP F which at the time
was owned by the Spanish oil and gas
company Repsol so those of you who are
from Spain or Latin America surely know
a lot about the details of this case for
those of you who aren't the key pieces
of information are 1yp F was for many
decades the state-owned oil company for
Argentina - it was a huge company one of
the absolute biggest companies in
Argentina and three a couple decades ago
y PF was privatized and sold to this
Spanish company Repsol which
the time was largely a down stream
actually sort of as fairly small
regional player in oil and gas in this
made Repsol suddenly one of the bigger
energy companies in the world so after
that happens a few layers later there's
a left-leaning populist government in
power in Argentina and what the
government did was via just an
exquisitely crafted set of political
maneuvers to get support from
state-level governments to get support
from citizens to claim credit for what
they're doing the government takes back
YP F from Repsol basically the President
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner stands up
on national TV to applause from the
entire legislature announcing this we
are reclaiming the the oil for ourselves
and you know she's behind her she has
his image of Evita perón so it's it's
just wonderful political theater and so
what's striking to me actually about
this in it is well what's striking to be
when I observe other examples of
outright expropriations whether it's by
like Chavez in Venezuela Gloria and
Ecuador Morales and Bolivia and the like
is it a lot of the time business
people's approach to understanding these
expropriations is to look at them and
say you know what's going on is we got a
government that's ideological they're
just completely oblivious to have basic
economics and they're essentially crazy
like a lot of business people talk about
populist politicians in these ways I
think it is true that the politicians
often are quite ideological but I think
it's also a serious strategic mistake to
think of them as being crazy and when I
talk to executives who've been involved
on the losing end in various
expropriations they often recognize
after the fact that the politicians were
following a logic in what they were
doing and it's a logic that is different
from the usual logics of business you
know politicians need to think about who
is my core support base what is going to
keep me in power and what are my
possibilities within existing and
potential
future political institutions and if we
think about politicians systematically
in those ways we often see that there
seemingly bits crazy behavior actually
makes more sense than it does if we just
you know take it from the perspective of
oh they're doing something that I don't
like and that I think is crazy and when
we do this we see that it's actually
possible for companies to formulate
strategies to deal with the threat of
expropriation instead of proactively
mitigate those risks not eliminate them
entirely but to state take steps that
reduce the sort of problems that they
might encounter so the third example I'm
gonna give I'm gonna come back to the
United States and this is the example of
health care reform in the United States
this obviously has been the topic of a
lot of turbulence in a high political
drama you know first in 2009 and 2010
we'll Obamacare chaos will it not pass
then more recently in 2017 and 2018
will it be repealed will it not be
repealed what sorts of things might the
administration do to try to undermine it
and make it fail as much as possible and
then try to change the policy all sorts
of things like that so this sort of
dynamic in changes in this enormous
industry we're talking a large
percentage of the gross national product
of the United States is in health care
this poses a major challenge to
companies in part because they need to
predict what is going to happen in
policymaking processes so if you think
about the current uncertainty
surrounding Obamacare and put yourself
from the perspective of a health
insurance company and you know there's
all this turbulence and turmoil and
there's attempts to undermine it the
question from an insurers perspective
right now the immediate question is how
does this affect the pool of people who
will buy health insurance on the
individual market and how does that
therefore affect how we should price any
products that we offer on the individual
markets or on the exchanges that's
actually a fairly hard problem for a lot
of companies to figure out it's a very
important one because billions of
dollars are at stake
now that said so that's one of the
challenges associated with these policy
changes but another thing to point out
is that dramatic policy changes also
often open up opportunities for
companies to make profits and succeed so
actually at the time that Obamacare was
passed in 29 to 2010 a lot of the major
health insurers were really pretty
strongly opposed to passage of Obamacare
and Ashley afterwards some of them
struggled to figure out how to price
their policies and actually exited the
individual market in very public ways
but at the same time some of these very
same insurers have figured out other
ways to succeed in the marketplace
making money as a result of this
government policy change and this is
especially due to the Medicare expansion
of the Medicaid expansion component of
Obamacare so many of the insurers that
oppose this program in the first place
are now I pulled on this is really good
this is a lot of our business we're
ensuring a bunch of people we weren't
previously you know making money off of
and insuring so this is a way that
companies by adapting to those policy
changes those dramatic and in some sense
turbulent policy changes we're able to
succeed in the marketplace now the final
example that I want to give is maybe the
example that you were most expecting
when you signed up for this webinar you
see like navigating business and
turbulent political times and you're
probably thinking trait because that's
the big one that's in the news right now
I mean aside from North Korea which is
currently dominating the news but trades
the one that's been in the big news for
the you know the past few weeks and I
think it's some ways what the United
States government has recently been
doing on trade is a major step away from
past practices so our policy is erratic
our policy process and procedure are
used the president's use of consultation
with his advisors is erratic and sort of
unpredictable we've invoked this
national security argument for
protectionism saying Canada invaded us
in 1812 and stuff like that and you know
that's kind of a different sort of
framing from
trade politics has traditionally been
handled in the United States but perhaps
most importantly has been this attempt
in the Trump admission administration to
switch from multilateral general trade
agreements to specific bilaterally
negotiated deals to make that change is
to make a fundamental change in the
structure of how trade is handled
globally going all the way back to the
set up of the institutions for trade in
the post-world War two period where the
night United States led a bunch of
countries to try to set up a set of
successful bilateral institutions now
that said about these changes it's also
important to recognize that there's many
ways that the politics of trade it's
actually pretty similar to how it's
always been so I'm gonna highlight some
of those things it's important not to
get too caught up in the new stuff in
the disruption and to be aware of what's
continued and what will continue to
shape the politics of trade going
forward first there is a big difference
between elite and mass opinion on trade
so politicians economists general elite
policymakers are generally much more
supportive of free trade and think it
has much better benefits than citizens
do on average there's a gulf between
elites and the masses that of course
raises the possibility of pandering by
elected officials if they say hold on to
get support from the public to win
elections and things like that maybe
it's useful for me to take positions
against free trade Donald Trump is not
the first politician to do this George W
Bush did this back when he imposed
tariffs on imported steel there were
huge rallies on the White House lawn
people talking about all the key
battleground states and elections are
states that produce steel you should
support the steel industry and George
Bush caved on that got criticized by
among others The Wall Street Journal
which should have been a natural ally of
his Bush wasn't the only one Hillary
Clinton initially was in favor of the
TPP treaty but then when she was running
for president in 2016 she all of a
sudden discovered that she had some
vague
can you know or some very grave
reservations about this and didn't
support it anymore and the like so it's
actually common to see these patterns in
how politicians shift in favor and out
of favor of trade depending on where
they are in political institutions what
political power they hold and whether
they're facing re-election soon the
second thing to note is that the
economics of trade fundamentally create
an asymmetry in the politics of trade so
consider one example consider steel
tariffs so who benefits from steel
tariffs well most obviously steel
companies maybe some of the steel
workers maybe the people in communities
surrounding the steel manufacturers
those folks are obviously going to be
engaged organized and politically active
and powerful on this issue
who's hurt by steel tariffs well
companies that use steel are hurt you've
actually seen some companies that use
steel or that trade a lot actually had
whenever the administration was
announcing steel or aluminum tariffs
substantial dips in their value in their
stock price so that suggested these
tears probably hurt them also companies
that benefit and in general participate
to a large degree in global trade
because they have to worry what if
there's a disruption of trade globally
now might be because those companies
produce specific products that can be
targeted in retaliatory tariffs you know
if you're a bourbon produce or a
motorcycle producer you have to be
worried about the retaliation that the
European Union might have in response to
trade restrictions imposed by the United
States on steel and aluminum coming from
those countries but those folks aren't
going to be quite as powerful in trying
to influence things on the issue of
steel tariffs and of course consumers
and regular citizens are in the view of
economists basically hurt by
restrictions on trade but it's not like
there's gonna be like some groundswell
of consumers trying to convince you know
politicians not to impose tariffs and
stuff like that so there's a real
asymmetry in what we call the
distributive politics of trade and
that's an example of the type of thing
that we analyze in the strategy beyond
markets program
so what sort of strategies does this
imply for companies well it could be
that companies might you know join
together and band together in an overall
push for free trade on everything every
type of good and service but that
probably isn't going to happen right
it's a collective action problem it's a
free rider problem most companies have a
natural tendency if I'm going to step
back let others take the lead on this
but it's more natural for companies to
do which probably isn't quite as good of
policy but is more natural as a strategy
thing for companies to do it suppose for
specific carve outs and exceptions say I
import this particular product I don't
want it to be subject to tear us or I'm
an exporter of some particular product I
want things to be done in a way where my
thing that I export isn't going to be
hit by retaliatory tariffs by some other
country or some other block so that's
just a few observations on the current
politics of trade I think we now have a
little bit of time for Q&A so we had a
participant in the webinar asking if one
of you want to make any comments on
corporate social responsibility and CSR
charters yeah so I think in terms of
corporate social responsibility you know
this is in some sense a form of self
regulation I mentioned earlier that
Steve and Donna and I have been thinking
about self regulation corporate social
responsibility is in some sense a way of
committing oneself as a company or
industry to hold to some standard that's
higher than what the law actually
requires now some companies do this for
moral motivations
now those moral motivations might be the
motivations of their c-suite executives
it might be the moral motivations of
their employees so some companies do CSR
policies I'm Intel for example I think
some of their policies on conflict
minerals are driven in part by Sisu the
executive opinion and also by the sense
of employees within the company and I
think CSR is a broadly useful tool for
building a general support base in a
society so actually when I was talking
about political risk earlier I realized
that
it might have come across when I said
you know you need to plan to manage the
threat of expropriation and things like
that and I I worried what if someone was
thinking I'm saying okay you know give
someone some money be corrupt or
something like that that's not what I
was saying actually what I meant by that
more precisely was you need to figure
out how to make it clear to people in
society that the benefits of your
company's business are broadly shared
and that's a reason why a lot of
companies that you know anticipate
themselves facing threats of
expropriation or various types of risks
engage in strategic CSR you touched on
this a little in the opening remarks but
the question came in asking if this
program is aimed just at public affairs
and government relations executives take
that one absolutely not
what we're focusing on is the
intersection of business and government
so what we're really the perspective
we're taking is the perspective of
business strategy how do businesses
strategize about this intersection with
government the media and society more
broadly so the focus for the class is
people running businesses are involved
in the management of businesses now
that's going to appeal to people who do
government relations public affairs
because they need to take a more
strategic perspective than just dealing
with the latest flare-up or the latest
problem of the day all right handling
crisis management by just delegating it
to the PR people is not enough it
typically leads to bad outcomes so what
we're trying to do is incorporate these
aspects of the business problem into the
everyday management problem
and so those for those people we're
trying to bring them closer to the
management problems they'll help them
understand the broader strategic problem
and for those running businesses we're
trying to help them understand the
broader strategic environment they sit
in all too often business people have
just focused on their customers their
suppliers and their employees well the
more the world is much bigger than that
and the problem you face is much broader
than that and what we see is that as
executives rise up in their organization
the higher and higher they get the more
they become aware of this problem the
more this problem starts to affect their
everyday life and determine their
success so what we're trying to do is to
develop the tools and the frameworks and
the theory and the skills to handle and
understand these problems and we're
trying to educate all of those groups be
it public affairs government relations
people or a general management about
this broader strategic problem
so that when they rise to senior
leadership or they're advising senior
leadership they can give advice that's
good for the organization and that's
optimal for the organization as a whole
Thanks I've got one more question so we
see companies moving fast to capture
market share grow and be at the edge of
innovation what are some signs and/or
early indicators that a company needs to
develop and execute a strategy to work
with or actively shape regulation and
oversight yeah that's a good question
that's become increasingly prominent in
recent times here particularly here in
Silicon Valley all right all too long
companies in Silicon Valley took pride
in that they ignored the government and
they would operate they would create
their new idea and they would tell me
and tell us we're changing the world
we're making the world a better place we
don't need government we don't care
about them just get out of our way and
all too often those companies eventually
ran into the problem of regulation and
the problem of government and when it
comes when you get that first sign that
you need it it's often too late all
right as Ken was talking about during
his remarks disruptive innovation is
great but the interest the company
that's disrupted it's not so great for
them and so the way this usually plays
out is the incumbents who may be getting
beaten in the market with this new
innovation turn to the beyond market to
solve their problem to protect their
market position so often the sign that
you've got a problem it's too late to
deal with it what is essential is that
from the very start and this is what
we're seeing now in Silicon Valley
amongst the venture capitalists and
amongst the startup community and we
teach every year to our MBAs
is to be thinking of that about this
beyond market problem at the initial
start of your business if you have a
market strategy but you don't have a
Beyond market strategy you're not
putting yourself in a position for
success so we think that this is just an
integral part of any business strategies
to be thinking about these issues
often what you can do is take actions to
avoid the regulatory problem or put
yourself in a better position to handle
it when it does arrive and I think those
are all the questions we have time for
okay you have some concluding remarks
yep great well thank you everyone for
joining us this morning
I hope you enjoyed the range of examples
we gave you about business making in
turbulent times what is common across
all these examples is that to succeed in
turbulent times requires a strategy
flailing away and then blaming the the
shocks and the turbulence itself isn't
going to get you very far so success
requires a strategy what we do at
Stanford keneniah and our research group
here is we develop these strategies
these tools these frameworks to help you
solve that problem all right it's a
difficult problem to solve but ignoring
it is not a solution developing the
strategies is going to put you in a much
better position for success we created
the strategy beyond markets program to
share these knowledge to share these
skills as broadly as possible we hope
you can join us this year or some other
year in the future thanks for joining us
this morning and have a great day
you
[Music]